ce célibataire s'est très bien où aller
une tourbière à 3 km
pourquoi est-il si pressé
parce qu'à destination il n'y aura
qu'une seule femelle pour 5 mâles
[Musique]
devant l'hôpital Saint-Raphaël de Milan
ou Silvio Berlusconi est décédé les
caméras s'installent alors que ses
proches son frère et ses enfants
arrivent auprès de sa dépouille les
hommages affluent à commencer par la
présidente du conseil et alliés
politiques Georgia Meloni
l'Italie a pris qu'elle ne devait jamais
se laisser imposer des limites où se
sentir vaincu
personnage de la carrière rythmée par
les scandales judiciaires et les
positions polémiques à l'internationale
c'est le chef d'état hongrois Victor
Orban qui le premier salut la mémoire
d'un grand combattant vient ensuite
Vladimir Poutine que Berlusconi avait
soutenu encore récemment au cœur de la
guerre en Ukraine il était un grand ami
de notre peuple et a beaucoup fait pour
développer des relations amicales entre
la Russie et les pays européens ce matin
les télévisions italiennes sont en
édition spéciale et sur sa chaîne les
présentateurs ont du mal à annoncer la
nouvelle
Silvio Berlusconi est mort
Francesco fait le toi moi je n'y arrive
pas
je te comprends en 2008 ces propos sur
Barack Obama le premier président noir
des États-Unis ont choqué parce qu'il
est jeune parce qu'il est beau et aussi
parce qu'il est bronzé sans filtre aussi
quand il parle des femmes
je déteste les femmes
au mieux je les considère tout juste bon
à rester dans leur cuisine
nous vous aimons nous vous aimons dans
les rues de Rome les Italiens accusent
le coup
ça me touche pour moi c'était un grand
patron il a donné du travail à beaucoup
de gens dans ce pays
tout sera un certain personne ne peut le
remplacer
quel célèbre JC serait né entre 4 et 7
ans avant lui-même
[Musique]
un JC célèbre
il y en a beaucoup
[Musique]
mais j'ai pas la suite
c'est juste ça
je pense que c'est fini en fait je pense
qu'effectivement c'est fini c'est trop
en fait il y a plus de solutions
comme personne ne veut faire changer de
logiciel complètement
ça fait 20 ans que on le dit waouh les
amis cette date sera a marqué d'une
pierre blanche nous venons d'apprendre
que quand on dit ça s'est passé en 200
avant JC ça s'est donc passé en 200
avant Jean-Claude
j'ai l'honneur de proposer au prochain
Conseil européen
quand dépit de son éloignement
géographique
Israël devienne un pays membres de
l'Union européenne
manifestement sans prévenir ces
homologues européens
votre voix au son caressants
il est murmure en fer
me verse de sa belle histoire
et malgré moi je veux y croire
[Musique]
vite moi des choses tendres
moi j'ai rien contre ces gens je trouve
ça grotesque moi aussi et ça m'agace
voilà mais je pense que tout le monde
sauf
les politiques
de bonnes à rien qui sont bonnes
et puis ton pote aussi là prends-le par
la main et puis vous allez vous mettre
un coup d'encre parce qu'elle prend qui
disait
sinon il a un 82 ans mais il est pas
capable d'en faire il y a quelques jours
la Belgique apprenez la mort de l'un de
ses tiktokers Ragnar le fou suivi par
plus de 150000 personnes repose en paix
papa je n'arrive pas à y croire pourquoi
la vie est si injuste mais alors que
certains de ses proches pleuraient sa
disparition l'homme a fini par
réapparaître bien vivant à la surprise
générale à ses propres funérailles en
hélicoptère une scène totalement
incroyable pour les invités présents aux
obsèques
vous savez ce qu'il faut faire faut
faire ce qu'on appelle un reset
sur la France
un grand reset un grand reset